der hauptfokus von uns liegt jetzt
natürlich auch der zusammenarbeit mit
buy und dem unternehmen gehabt was heute
die nachricht verkündet hat dass er uns
sagen die erste studie eines
impfstoffkandidaten gegen caen mit 19
jetzt in deutschland gestartet werden
kann wir sind partner von biotech in der
entwicklung eines solchen impfstoffes
und es ist natürlich jetzt ein
besonderer tag auch dass wir heute
sagten deutschland mit dem start dieses
dann weltweiten programms beginnen also
beginnen können und die ersten ersten
studien anlaufen können
die erwartungen sind groß hatte
geschildert dass man eben hofft wir alle
hoffen dass man den stoff hat aber wenn
man sozusagen auf die zeit leisten
gruppe normalerweise brauche noch jahre
bis sie entwickelt werden
insofern hinblick auf diese zeit leisten
ist das ein atemberaubendes tempo was
was dort sozusagen jetzt stattgefunden
hat faisabad tag abend alle ihre kräfte
experten zusammengebracht um jetzt
sozusagen in dieser in dieser phase
hinein zu gehen
diese geschwindigkeit denn ich war
möglich weil zum einen bei a-tec viel
erfahrung hat mit dieser neuen
technologie messenger rna impfstoffe
sind das eine ganz neue gruppe von
impfstoffen falls auf der anderen seite
viele jahre lang erfahrung hat in der
impfstoffentwicklung sozusagen unsere
ganzen experten aus forschung
entwicklung klinischer prüfung zulassung
sozusagen dort bereits mit in die
zusammenarbeit in ahlen gebracht haben
und beide unternehmen sich auch schon
gut kennen wir sind bereits seit zwei
jahren auch in einer kollaboration zu
messenger rna impfstoffe in anderen
indikationen also als das denke ich hat
eine gute grundlage geschaffen jetzt ist
der erste schritt gemacht
ein ganz wichtiger sieg vom
paul-ehrlich-institut hat es ja gerade
beschrieben wir haben jetzt natürlich
noch eine ganze strecke vor uns in der
klinischen entwicklung und es ist von
der jetzigen warte aus ihm schwer
abzuschätzen wann ist nun genau sein
wird den zeithorizont ist gerade
aufgezeigt worden mit blick aufs nächste
jahr
jetzt ist wichtig dass sozusagen die
ersten schritte gemacht werden dass die
sicherheit getestet wird das geschaut
wird wie die immunogenität aussieht die
wirkung und dass wir da nicht im schritt
für
in die weiteren phasen der klinischen
entwicklung gehen können was dann auch
ganz wichtig wird es wenn wir dann
hoffentlich auch ein impfstoff
kandidaten haben werden
da müssen wir ihn auch in ausreichender
menge produzieren also produktion wird
auch ein ganz wesentliches thema dabei
sein
dazu würde ich gerne dann einmal
professoren kunden damit in unser
gespräch einbinden dr professor pointner
die frage die sich ganz normale menschen
im moment natürlich stellen die bitte
eines eben schon auch angesprochen hat
warum dauert das eigentlich so lange so
ein impfstoff erst zu entwickeln und
dann herzustellen
ja grundsätzlich ja grundsätzlich ja da
und ich werde sein ganz besonderer
aspekt den man berücksichtigen muss
nämlich dass ein impfstoff gesunden
verabreicht wird und das ist ein großer
unterschied als ob ich ein arzneimittel
einem sehr schwer erkranken verabreiche
das sind die da sind einfach die
anforderung an das sicherheitsprofil
ganz andere und das ist in der
impfstoffentwicklung ähnlich wie in der
arzneistoff entwicklung zum einen herr
professor biotech hat es gerade
angesprochen muss man wissen welche
dosis überhaupt zum einsatz kommt
dafür gibt es dann verschiedene phasen
der klinischen entwicklung wo man testet
ob das arzneimittel bar in der anwendung
beim menschen oder der impfstoff
überhaupt sicher und verträglich ist
dann nähert man sich schrittweise der
dosis muss es einmal gegeben werden
mehrfach gegeben werden das muss im test
ein bestätigt werden dann geht es darum
ein bizarres gerade angesprochen die
immunogenität wie stark ist die
immunantwort also die klinische wirkung
des wachsens und das muss alles
ausgewertet werden und das braucht
normalerweise wenn alles wahnsinnig
schnell geht braucht das 34 jahre und
dann müssen sie ja im hintergrund noch
die produktionskapazität
entsprechend hoch waren das heißt das
sind prozesse die in der regel von der
entwicklung bis zur vermarktung jahre
brauchen ich bin allerdings
zuversichtlich
mit der kompetenz und der bisher nie
dagewesenen bereitschaft zur kooperation
in allen fällen ich glaube es war
vielleicht bei hiv aids ähnlich wie
behörden zulassungsbehörden wie politik
wie industrie die akademie die
wissenschaft zusammengearbeitet dass es
uns gelingen sollte
mit dem modernen technologien
tatsächlich im nächsten jahr einen
solchen impfstoff der auch in großen
mengen produziert werden kann
entsprechend auch zur verfügung zu haben